this bus is evacuating the first batch
of chinese citizens from ukraine
chinese state media say the group of 600
people mostly students have been taken
from the cities of kiev and odessa to
neighboring moldova
but many others have been left behind
zhang dongsha has been frantically
packing his bags and plans to catch a
train to ukraine's west from the eastern
city of denipro where he studies
it's hard for us to fall asleep at night
because you're always afraid
and the air defense sirens keep going
off
he says the chinese embassy has been
concentrating on evacuating people from
areas affected by fighting but he's
worried the conflict will soon reach
denipro more than 6 000 chinese
nationals in ukraine are trying to leave
they're being encouraged to take trains
to neighbouring countries chartered
flights are also planned
the current situation is complex and
volatile the foreign ministry and the
chinese embassy in ukraine are closely
following the situation and studying all
possible ways to assist chinese citizens
to evacuate voluntarily and safely
despite chinese students and workers
expressing concerns about their safety
online it's taken longer for china to
pull its people out than other countries
beijing has close ties with moscow and
has refused to condemn the russian
attack
instead blaming nato and the us for
increasing tensions
state media has downplayed reports of
destruction in ukraine calling the
invasion a special military operation
some social media users have posted
comments in favor of russian president
vladimir putin supporting what they say
is his war against the west
china's foreign ministry says its
strategic partners with russia not
allies it cannot afford to offend moscow
but has also emphasized its friendly
relationship with kiev china is
ukraine's number one trading partner and
a major source of foreign investment
jiangdong says the perception that china
backs russia has stoked anti-chinese
sentiment there
ukrainians have a bad impression of the
chinese and some may be anti-china if
your family members join the army or die
and they think china supports russia it
makes me feel scared so i didn't want to
stay i want to leave last week chinese
citizens were advised to display their
national flag when traveling as a safety
precaution
the chinese officials reversed that
instruction a day later saying they
should be careful when revealing their
nationality katrina u al jazeera beijing